hast du kinder
hast du kinder ja ich habe
ja ich habe einen sohn
ja ich habe eine tochter
ja
ich habe eine tochter
ja ich habe zwei söhne
[Musik]
ja ich habe zwei töchter
nein ich habe keine kinder
hast du geschwister hast du geschwister
ja ich habe einen bruder
ja ich habe eine schwester
ja ich habe zwei brüder
ja ich habe zwei schwestern
nein ich bin ein einzelkind
bist du verheiratet bist du verheiratet
ja ich bin verheiratet
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet
nein ich bin ledig nein ich bin ledig
nein ich bin geschieden
hast du einen freund hast du einen
freund
ja ich habe einen freund
nein ich habe keinen freund
hast du eine frau
hast du eine freundin
ja ich habe eine freundin
nein ich habe keine freundin
hast du ein haustier hast du ein
haustier
ja ich habe eine katze ja ich habe eine
katze ja ich habe einen hund ja ich habe
einen hund
nein ich habe kein haustier
wohin gehst du
ich gehe in
schule
ich gehe in die schule
[Musik]
ich gehe ins einkaufszentrum
ich gehe
ins einkaufszentrum ich gehe
das restaurant
ich gehe ins restaurant
ich gehe in die bank
ich gehe an die bushaltestelle
er geht
den supermarkt er geht in den supermarkt
er geht in den kleiderladen er geht in
den kleiderladen er geht ins kino
er geht ins kino
er geht ins fitness center
ich lege mich ins bett
ich lege den teppich auf den boden
ich stelle die gläser in sub waschbecken
ich stelle das velo in die garage ich
stelle das velo in die garage
ich stelle die schuhe vor die tür
ich hänge das kleid an den
kleiderständern
ich hänge das bild an die wand
er trägt einen schal um den hals
er trägt einen verband um den kopf
das auto fährt durch den tunnel
ihr atmen durch die nase wir atmen durch
die nase
das medikament ist gegen das fieber das
medikament ist gegen das fieber
die tabletten sind gegen die schmerzen
gib mir bitte einen
kugelschreiber gib mir bitte einen
kugelschreiber schaltete das licht aus
schalte bitte das licht aus
mach bitte das fenster auf
mach bitte das
fenster auf
mach bitte die tür zu machte die tür zu
ich gehe in den keller
ich gehe in
den keller
sie setzt sich auf den stuhl
die katze klettert auf den baum hat auf
den wangen
sie hängt die hose an den
kleiderständern
ich gehe in die bäckerei
ich lege mich aufs sofa
[Musik]
er stellt das sofa vor das fenster
ich gehe in die apotheke
ich gehe in die küche
ich gehe in die disco
in den zoo
ich gehe in den zoo
gehe in den garten
ich gehe ins museum
ich gehe in die 4
ferien
ich gehe in die ferien
[Musik]
ich gehe ans konzert
ich gehe auf die wiese
möchtest du noch andere sprachen lernen
lernen mit unseren partnern englisch
oder portugiesisch
oder spanien
oder china